[Music]
philip k dick in his address the android
and the human is going to
focus
in part on differentiating the two
from each other and you might say well
how can that be difficult
androids or androids robots of some sort
human beings are living breathing
entities obviously they're different
from each other and dick says well
it's not quite so simple there are a
number of ways in which human beings can
be as he says instruments means rather
than ends and hence to me
analogs of machines in the bad sense in
the sense that although
biological life continues metabolism
goes on the soul for lack of a better
term is no longer there or at least no
longer
active the reduction of humans to mere
use men made into machines serving a
purpose which although good in an
abstract sense has for its
accomplishment employed what i regard as
the greatest evil imaginable the placing
on what was a free man who laughed and
cried and made mistakes and wandered off
into foolishness and play
a restriction that limits him despite
what he may imagine or think to the
fulfilling of a name
outside of his own personal however puny
destiny and
this is something that he he thinks
hasn't
uh you know developed as something
unique within our late modern
technological age but
we're at significantly greater risk of
this happening to ourselves and to those
we care about and to other human beings
more generally in part because of the
development and proliferation of
technology but also
because of what we can call techniques
or
modes of of using the human being
organizing what he'll actually call
a science and he talks about production
of inauthentic human activity and
governments and other things like them
which could include for example
corporations in our own time
have developed something that they can
call sciences
to make this happen
and he asks a key question that we
should be
very concerned with he says i would like
to ask this
what is it
in our behavior
that we can call
specifically human that is special to us
as a living species and then by contrast
what is it at least up till now we can
consign as merely machine behavior
or now notice what he says here
insect behavior
reflex behavior by extension so
dick thinks that at least at a certain
level of animality
animals are basically like
machines and insects he thinks are very
much like that but we move up into the
higher orders and we get to you know the
mammals and i think he would probably in
the present include birds in there as
well
and then we get to the distinctively
human so what separates humans from
androids and a very early question or
very early answer that he provides is
when he's talking about youth and their
rebelliousness
and uh what is
you know going on in this resistance and
he says that
one of the things that's
central to human beings even if they're
not particularly important human beings
is a kind of irreplaceability
he says
even the most base schemes of human
beings are preferable to the most
exalted tropisms of
machines and he says i think this right
here is one of the valid insights
possessed by some of the new youth cars
even police cars are expendable
they can be replaced they're really all
alike it is the person inside who when
gone
cannot be duplicated at any price even
if we don't like him
we cannot do without him and once gone
he will never come back and then too if
he is made into an android he will never
come back never be again human or anyhow
most likely
will not so irreplaceability
irreplaceability doesn't mean that every
single person is a delicate snowflake
and the cosmos you know needs each one
in its single place that's not that sort
of thing
there's just a more raw you can't
replace this this person even though
they might be a dork or a schmuck or you
know a terrible person
you can't effectively replace them with
an android unless they've already become
like an android themselves so that's one
and then we've talked about here's the
second criterion we've talked about this
means and ends thing already a little
bit earlier and he says that
becoming what i call for lack of a
better term an android means
to allow oneself to become a means
that is something that is used in order
to produce something else
right and the means could be uh somebody
else's pleasure it could be productivity
it could be keeping the other androids
or human beings in line it could be
whatever you like but you if you're an
android you are a mere means a tool an
instrument
and he says to become a means or
to be pounded down manipulated
made into a means without one's
knowledge or consent the results
are the same and he goes on and says
androidism requires
obedience and predictability and that's
what we want of
means so that we can actually use them
without thinking too much about the
means that we're relying upon you know
very often we have a tool and we're not
even paying attention to the tool until
something goes wrong and then we're like
why is this piece of chalk not writing
the way that i want on my blackboard now
we're paying attention to right there's
been a
breakdown in the mechanism but we don't
ask the chuck what would you like do you
have any goals
aspirations dreams preferences no we
just make it do its work as a means
the third thing that he talks about and
here he brings up a term from psychology
of the time schizoid which was used both
as a diagnosis and in the broader
culture
it's kind of dropped out of parlance in
in the broader culture
now
and he says that the schizoid is is
similar to the android how so he says in
the field of abnormal psychology
the schizoid personality structure is
well defined in it there is a
continual paucity
of feeling a lack of feeling a lack
where there should be
something there and then he goes on and
says this person thinks rather than
feels their way
through life
and he says there's a certain parallel
between the android personality and the
schizoid both have a mechanical
reflex quality i once heard a schizoid
person express himself in all
seriousness this way i receive signals
from others but i can't generate any of
my own until i get recharged by an
injection i am i swear quoting exactly
imagine viewing oneself and others this
way signals
the person is rayified that has turned
themselves into a thing himself entirely
along with everyone around him
here clearly he says the soul is dead or
has never
lived so
thinking being cerebral being cognitive
lacking the affective or having a
flattening of affect is another sign of
the android and you can think you know
how we're we've got all these ideas
about we're gonna you know make robots
or ai's that have genuine feelings
how the hell is that gonna work we don't
even have consensus in psychology about
what the basic emotions are there's a
number of different theories out there
and yet the rest of us were able to you
know go along for example i'm kind of
excited right now talking about this i
think you could probably
grasp the passion that i have for these
ideas and for philip k dixoff that is a
sort of non-android response that an
android might be able to mimic
but probably could never
understand
another fourth criterion that he gives
us
the android has an inability
to make exceptions and here he says
perhaps this is the essence of it the
failure to drop a response when it fails
to accomplish results
repeating it over and over again and he
says lower life forms are skillful in
offering the same response continually
as our flashlights and now he's he says
something really quite interesting he's
got this thing about a pigeon he says an
attempt was made to use a pigeon as a
quality control technician on an
assembly line
part after part endless thousands of
them passed the pigeon hour by hour and
the kenai of the pigeon viewed them for
deviations from the acceptable tolerance
the pigeon could discern a deviation
smaller than that of a human doing the
same quality control so when he saw a
part that was mismade it pecked a button
rejected the part dropped a grain of
corn to the pigeon as a reward the
pigeon could go 18 hours without fatigue
and loved its work even when the grain
corn failed
the pigeon continued eagerly to reject
substandard parts and now dick says if i
was that pigeon i would feel cheated
when i felt hungry i would just peck the
the button and reject the part to get my
grain of corn that would have occurred
to me after a long period passed in
which i discerned no faulty parts
what would happen to the pigeon if god
forbid no parts were ever faulty the
pigeon would starve integrity under such
circumstances would be
suicidal really the pigeon had a life
and death interest in finding faulty
parts what would you do if you were in
that
would ethics win out or the need to
survive
the android would say the android mind i
am dying of hunger but i'll be damned if
i reject a perfectly good part and dick
says the authentically human mind would
get rid would get bored and reject a
part now and then at random just to
break the monotony and he says
um
[Music]
this helps us to see
the difference between the android and
the human the android can't make
exceptions or if they make exceptions
it's got to be according to some rule
and then we could say are there
exceptions that rule we can go on from
there
then dick brings up another thing and he
uses an example that i'm not going to go
into here because it's quite lengthy but
he talks about
an essential key
revealing the authentically human now
the distinctions that we've been making
up until this point assume sort of a
nature already in place a human nature
and dick says you know we do have a
human nature and we need to understand
it because no matter where we go if we
go to the stars we're bringing that
human nature along with us
but and here's where dick is you know
kind of existentialist
that human nature is not something we
can just simply take for granted
it is something that we
walk into we enter into we develop into
through how we are in situations he says
this is not only an intrinsic property
of the organism the human being but the
situation in which it finds itself
that which happens to it
that which is confronted by
pierced by
and must deal with
certain agonizing situations create
on the spot
a human
where a moment before there was only as
the bible says
clay
and he says something very interesting
here
this is you know a possibility of our
technological age
he says this is also something that we
can see in the medieval pietas the
medieval
shows the dead christ
cradled in the arms of his mother two
faces actually that of a man that of a
woman oddly in many of these piatas the
face of christ seems much older than his
mother it is as if an ancient man is
held by a young woman she has survived
him and yet she came before him he has
aged through his entire life cycle
and he is she he goes on and says he has
not
survived it it shows on his face
she
looks now perhaps as she always did not
timeless in the classic sense but able
to transcend what has happened in some
way they have experienced it together
but they have come out of it differently
it was too much for him it destroyed him
perhaps the information to be gained
here is to realize how much greater
capacity a woman has for suffering that
is not that she suffers more than a man
but that she can endure where he can't
christ might may die on the cross and
the human race continues but if mary
dies
it's all over
and then he goes on and he says
i've seen you know young people
survive things that would have been too
much for me
their humanness as they pass through
these ordeals developed as an equation
between them and their situation
i don't mean to offer now he's very
important the mushy doctrine that's
suffering somehow in nobles that it's
somehow a good thing
you one hears this about geniuses they
wouldn't have been geniuses if they
hadn't suffered i merely mean that
possibly the difference between what i
call the android mentality and the human
now here's a beautiful phrase
is that the latter passed through
something the former did not
or at least passed through it
and responded differently
changed altered what it did and hence
what it was
it became i sense the android repeating
over and over again some limited reflex
gesture like an insect raising its wings
threateningly over and over again
remitting a bad smell
but caught in sudden trouble the
organism that is made more human that
becomes precisely at that moment human
wrestles deep within itself and out of
itself to find one response after
another as each fails
and so this is
something that
is hard to you know define
but
is essential
to the human
now he finishes up at the very end by
sketching out for us a funny situation
and then following it up with another
one
he talks about a computer and the
computer you know might be churning out
things uh like in the beginning was the
end and the end was the beginning
and he says perhaps when a computer is
ready to turn forth one or the other of
these two statements an android
operating the computer will make the
decision right so the android is in a
certain sense superior to a mirror
computer
and then he says although if i'm correct
about the android mentality
it will be unable to decide and will
print out both at once creating a
self-cancelling nothing which will not
even serve as a primordial chaos there's
no creativity there and android he says
might however be able to handle this
capable of some sort of decision making
power it might conceivably pick one
statement or the other is quote correct
but no android and you will recall and
realize by this term i'm summing up that
which is not human
no android would think to do what a
bright-eyed little girl i know did
something a little bizarre certainly
ethically questionable in several ways
at least in any traditional sense but to
me
truly human
in that it shows to me a spirit of merry
defiance of spirited though not
spiritual bravery and uniqueness and
what is this
one day while driving in her car she
found herself following a truck carrying
cases of coca-cola bottles case after
case stacks of them and when the truck
parked she parked behind it and loaded
the back of her own car with cases as
many cases of bottles of coca-cola as
she could get in so for weeks afterwards
she and her friends had all the
coca-cola they could drink free and when
the bottles were empty she carried them
to the store and turned them in for the
deposit refund right and
dick sees this as sort of like
distinctively human as something in
android
it wouldn't even occur to it to do that
unless you programmed you know thief
android or something like that and then
it would merely be acting out of its
programming or circuitry
so
this shows this spontaneity
uh of thinking in terms of means and
ends and actually serving the ends of
oneself and one's friends
shows another way of distinguishing the
humans from the android so dick has
given us a number of very important
considerations we're thinking about how
it is that human beings so long as they
haven't been reduced to
a analog of an android
so long as that's not the case how they
differ
from androids and can be expected to
differ
probably going deep into our
future where dick says we actually live
this distinction will probably continue
to hold
you